everything is love classic and chic as
beyonce and jay-z stunned during their
italian getaway that's what we do
[Music]
the couple attended a wedding in venice
italy on saturday the 40 year old singer
and the 51 year old music mogul were
guests at d street founder geraldine
guyat and executive vice president of
product and communications of tiffany
and company alexander arnold's special
day it's pretty amazing speaking of
amazing the pair were a sight to see as
they were photographed walking hand in
hand at the wedding beyonce wore a black
coat with a mint dress underneath she
accessorized with mint heels silver
jewelry and a bedazzled clutch purse
jay looks sophisticated and suave in a
double-breasted dark suit with a white
shirt and dark tie i am the happiest
i've ever been and i feel the most
empowered b and j who appeared to have
arrived in italy earlier this week were
glowing in these photos that the singer
shared on instagram the shots include
her and her husband on a boat which
looks similar to the ones celebs are
seen while in the city's canals beyonce
also showed fans a full shot of her
stunning blue and white printed custom
dolce gabbana gown which included a
matching mask
it just makes me
feel so lucky to be a woman we are
the
ish well queen bee continued to prove
how much of the iss she really is when
she posted these photos rocking another
look a black alice in olivia blazer
vintage jean-paul gautier top and saint
laurent pants
she's a
super um
detail oriented e.t caught up with her
hubby hove at the 18th anniversary of
his 40-40 club in new york city back in
august where he gushed about his wife of
13 years
obviously as you can see from her work
and she's uh incredibly hard worker
super talented
very inspiring
[Music]
you